russia has been marking the 76th
anniversary of its victory in the second
world war with a massive display of
military strength on moscow's red square
more than 10 000 soldiers took part
russian president vladimir putin was on
hand for the event
this year's parade comes amid increased
tensions with the west and neighbouring
ukraine which accuses russia
of amassing troops at its border
our bureau chief yuri rochetto has more
for us from moscow yuri
who's this show of military strength
directed at
of course rebecca this parade is first
and foremost a very large and glamorous
show it's a huge display of military
might
moscow's foreign policy is clearly
backed by military muscle
many who see today's spirit for example
especially the people in
neighboring ukraine will certainly think
of the russian troops on the ukrainian
border
just recently the russian armed forces
carried out large-scale and heavy
military
exercises there they stayed on russian
soil but
they were extremely close to the
ukrainian border the big war that some
people feared didn't
materialize but the question is how
quickly such a situation can repeat
itself
in addition to the conflict with ukraine
russia has also been involved in the
syrian conflict for years
the kremlin is fighting international
terrorism there in syria
at least that's the official reason for
the military operation there
against the backdrop of these conflicts
today's victory day parade
uh feels here in moscow like a message
to the world
not to mess with russia
it's been 76 years since the war ended
but this is still a hugely important
event in russia
why why does victory day mean so much
for russian people
well look today's parade is an important
part of the patriotic education of
people in russia but today is about much
more than patriotism just on a
government level we have to keep in mind
rebecca that today is a very special day
for millions of russian families
and not only russians but also
ukrainians belarusians
kazakhs uzbeks all the people of the
former soviet union because no other
country in the world
suffered as many victims in the world
war ii as the soviet union
that is why millions of families will
celebrate this day at home with friends
and relatives as well as with
walks and festivals in their home cities
now yuri such pomp and ceremony but we
can't forget that this parade's
happening in the middle of a pandemic
and
the russian infection rates are still
quite high what precautions are being
taken
yeah absolutely official russia is still
affected by the pandemic and officially
some restrictions in public life will
also apply here
but look these restrictions are nothing
compared to the lockdown in western
europe
outwardly moscow doesn't look like a
city hit by the pandemic
but first of all the vaccination
campaign has been up and running in
russia for months and anyone who
wants to get vaccinated against comet 19
free of charge can do it
although the roll out has been slow as
people prove
deeply reluctant to be injected
independent surveys found
only 30 percent of russians willing to
receive the russian vaccine sputnik v
one of the reasons is that russians are
conservative they don't trust their own
state
and they don't trust whatever can come
out of this
state all right yuri thank you very much
for that
dw's moscow bureau chief yuri rochetto